nel mentre ragazzi che ero in giappone è
esplosa questa questa moda degli scp su
minecraft mi fa un sacco reader ragazzi
perché gli scp che io giocavo da anni
tipo da sei anni fa ci ho giocato la
prima volta sc p non si è mai cagati
troppo nessuno invece da quando li hanno
messi su minecraft sono professioni
proviamolo sono arrivato un pelino tare
i ragazzi l'appuntamento con gli scp che
sarebbero queste creature che sono state
create dagli scienziati che facciamo
degli esperimenti che poi sono andati
tutti malissimo e le creature hanno
tutti i poteri strani particolari e tele
becchi tutte tu in faccia questa è la
trama di sgb praticamente credo che gli
scp sono gli stessi del gioco originale
quindi vediamo se riesco di incontrare
gli stessi so che alcuni non li devi
guardare dritti negli occhi se no ti
spaccano
insomma determinate cose che possono
succedere partiamo ragazzi allora
l'obiettivo è quello di riuscire ad
attivare ovviamente anche la corrente
perché non c'è corrente in tutto sto
casino
buongiorno sono quello che deve attive
sono l'elettricista giorno e ci sono
anche gli zombie normali ci mancava solo
questo perfetto ecco gli zombie normali
e chissà di livello di richiesta aiuto
aiuto mi sono fregato la somma si
possono disputare che già un casino
facciamo così spetta disponiamo i mostri
disponiamo i mostri oggi ai ragazzi
teoricamente ci dovremmo essere aperto
la porta quindi possiamo andare avanti o
destinati i mostri perché sono un casino
devo assolutamente trovare la corrente
devo tirare sulla corrente perché sono è
un problema qua buongiorno chiave di
livello 4 richiesta va bene allora
cerchiamo la maga schifo ma no ai ragni
ma no che schifo anche ragni sono persi
condizione cioè i peggiori scp che
esistano i ragnetti maledizione che
schifo c'è una porta che lampeggia fermi
tutti zitti
ci sono ragni ci sono tv eccomi perfetto
e tutto che lampeggia in questo posto
aiuto permesso che bello ma dai hanno
fatto il computer geniale
www.youtube.com igiene tv iscriviti
calcola era esattamente quello che
volevo shadow vi infestation che
successo infestazioni dell'oscurità
aiuto vuol dire fermi si possono aprire
i comodini
ma il geniale nuova ragazza aveva fatto
benissimo a parte i ragni che potranno
evitarli alla pazienza per tutto per oh
mio dio che ansia questo si cessi i
cessi buongiorno cos'è la mucca c'è una
mucca nei bagni ragazzi 3d specs mio dio
la torcia va bene perfetto la torcia per
la flashlight almeno vedo tavolo
illumina e bellissimo hai fatto
benissimo
va bene ci sono altri ce si sentono che
io io sento solo multi level five chi
cordio toto la testa a livello cinque
ragazzi io sento mucche però è diventato
un horror in piena regola questa cosa
l'aver forre qua adesso al livello 5
sono degli archivi night vision goggle
padova da quando ci credo è bellissimo
ma è bellissimo ferri tutti zitti è
bellissimo lo dai
allora mi sono armato di cacciavite c'è
solo un cacciavite il cacciavite ci
servirà per difenderci da fermi tutti
zitti ecco scassata board scusatemi non
volevo ho schiacciato la porta ecco
ci sono delle mucche insieme ai ragni di
prima buongiorno electrical chantre
centrare perfetto chiave livello 2 frega
niente perché cielo cos'è questo stampa
mista fanno i compiti la versa la carta
stampa che bastiglia forse perché devo
attivare giustamente la corrente se non
va la stampante buongiorno ho attivato
la luce c'è la luce
e luce fu posso adesso stampare funzioni
corrente o non funziona dei ct ecco
livello 3 di qua mi sa che si va a nelle
nelle stanze quelle più segrete qua
ragazzi siamo messi male ve lo dico se
ne becca un scp scp 538 allora ragazzi
ogni scp a un suo bene ogni esse ci
pisciano la sua particolarità io questo
non so cosa sia sono armato solo di
cacciavite
salve buongiorno
stava scherzando la parola dati fastidio
chiudi la porta ce l'ha fatta
si no la porta non si è chiusa ma non è
entrato perché troppo ciccione non c
entra sma e spari e pazzo se n'è andato
proprio non c'è più ed è fra c'era
invece ce l'abbiamo noi non giochiamo
quelle sociali non ci giudichi la
partita porta la porta che vi ha portato
alta chiodi non c entra e pazzo ma noi
come fai a non entrarci dev'essere che
troppo gradazione seymour gisci dai
ragazzi lasciamolo perdere scp 718
questo mi sa che un po più difficile
allora leste cp7 in questo qua non mi
ricordo che cosa dovevo fare quello di
prima al scp 718 tantomeno credo che il
colore significhi la pericolosità delle
scp quindi questo caso è rosso beh bello
si è è scappato cosa è successo è andato
di sopra o forse si vede solo con lei
treason può essere no ragazzi sscp è
scappato veramente tantissimo vediamo ci
dell ariston con sopra non ho capito che
via via via chissenefrega
non c'è le sc p questo qua meno male
meno male mamma mia ragazzi che kakà
devo passare per forza riguarda le
andare avanti perchè c'è il laboratorio
perché c'è il corridoio che mi porta
dall'altra parte però c'è il tizio non
c'è più eccola ancora scherzavo
scherzavo aiuto ai a mamma mia che male
pensavo che non mi sa tanto che non mi
ha attaccato e troverò non mi attaccano
mi attaccano mi fanno malissimo ma solo
il cacciavite posso menarlo l'acqua
dalla porta ma dov'è stato spari ma
dalla ragazzi ma levano tantissimo sono
impossibili da battere aiuto solo questo
come arma da qualcuno mi dia un arma vi
prego ognuno c'è il proprio modo di
essere battuto teoricamente come se c'è
questo qua non lo so come si fa su solo
che lo sto picchiando procacciamento
ragazzi la spada e l'unico modo che ho
di bath mamma mia che male che mi fa se
mi tocca sono morto praticamente quindi
vorrei evitare
ok perfetto c'è nessun ora grazie
vi prego non buttate viene addosso
nessun altro perché sto male sennò c'è
già quello era impossibile o sentito
qualcosa provenire dalle ventole ragazzi
non mi piace livello 1 recoarese usiamo
livello 3 a non è niente di ma le mie
orecchie stanno aiuto mi stanno
esplodendo le orecchie cosa succede data
storage apriti veloce nord giorni se c'è
mitico scherzavo scherzavo è perché dai
miei successo qualcosa qualcuno mi
avesse una maledizione addosso cos'è
successo scpa josè sperano che livello
uno di quei ragazzi se entrando nelle
stanze che non so dove su entrando ma
miss inserti paper cielo al bay per
potre cuore i ragazzi vorrei veramente
trovare dei maiali per strada perché ho
bisogno di ucciderli fortissimo però non
li trovo prima li ho trovati o sto
impazzendo
poi non è possibile come che sento villa
gergo che diamo di qualche non ci sono
ancora andato permesso storage area
perfetto livello 5 no non aprì la porta
solo tasto per aprire la porta non c'era
il tasto ok ragazzi son tornato con un
po di cibo anche qualche a roma perché
sono vero veramente nella cacca però non
ho più il google che gli oggetti cioè io
poi dietro stare attento perché non c'è
più il tasto per tornare se muoio
ho preso un po di roba dove cerca di
recuperare il più possibile però non so
dove col tizio eccolo
vistosa ma sono scemo uccidendo uccidi
non ci riuscirò dai fuori fuori quanto
duri
no ragazzi ma sugli impatti ma sono
fortissimi buongiorno store hajjar e
allora amico mio
stavolta ti ammazzo ti ammazzo una
famiglia o che ciò le cose non vi fate
vedere lo sapevo io vi siete ingabbiati
esclusi porca vacca è morto subito
perfetto dovetto cugino eccolo dove tuo
zio
qualcun altro va bene è chiusa in
sostanza che sono entrato otto volte
sono morto otto volte questa è la nona
isef o per fermo cielo è macello non
rompere i tre quarti ora quante torce
top 25 data 5 dato a far inserimento tv
trovare tutte le stampanti e inserirla
in tutte le stampanti può essere qui ne
mancano 5 quindi se vado nell'altro
lorenzo 4 giusto allora l'altro card
reader dovrebbe eccolo quale doveva
essere 44 l'altra falsare mei ling
perfetto devo trovare gli altri 4 2 che
sono niente ragazzi down ora che giro
veramente non riesco a trovare altre
stampanti impossibile anche perché ai
ragazzi in quel un episodio di sc
piccotti però nel prossimo perché
vedrete che cosa è successo
diciamo che stavo cercando di mettere a
punto le i file dentro le stampanti ma
devo chiudere la prima parte che è un po
per farvi capire come funzionava la
parte 2 è veramente incredibile sono un
esperto nel chiudere i video nei punti
focali però vedrete all'inizio del
prossimo questo è successo
ragazzi io concludo che episodio vi
ringrazio per la visione devo imparare a
riconoscere bene tutti gli esseri cp per
capire come affrontarli tutti quanti ma
ce la faremo senza problemi perché io ho
già giocato ad esserci piccolo normale
quello che vedete qua dietro vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa è sempre più
scoperto di 10.000 al prossimo scp e noi
ci vediamo anche come sempre hanno
proseguito se trovassi il telecomando
beh ragazzi
[Musica]